what's the craziest thing you think is
possible right obviously understand this
is a building block and we can only see
so far into the future it's super foggy
when you look too far but like
what is the thing that you're like you
know what i do think that this will
happen
what i think happens more than anything
is changing the incentive structures of
the world um in bitcoin miami
breedlove had a good conversation with
jordan peterson and they talked about
how if everybody's playing the game
everybody's playing together and
everyone's productive because everyone's
enjoying playing the game they're all
working together but if half the people
had to step out of the game to enforce
the remaining have to play the game
you've lost productivity because now
half the people have to force the other
people but also when they're forcing the
other half of the people they don't
really want to play anymore so their
productivity goes down and that's kind
of the environment that we're in today
so imagine if we change the incentive
structure to where everybody can play
the game together how much better the
world could be
we have a fight a fiat money system
that's losing value so we used to be
able to save money in dollars today we
used to we we've uh we've had progress
because the specialization of labor
right so if i could be the best brain
surgeon i could be maybe i could change
the world but today i have to be half
brain surgeon half investor yeah i talk
all the time about uh we ask teachers to
go be the best teachers in the world go
be the best accountant go be the best
marketing manager whatever and then oh
by the way nights and weekends like
become a great investor so you can
protect your purchasing power yeah like
that is so weird we've lost massive mind
share so i look at how much different
could the world be if everybody was
providing value as far as what
technologies could be built it's very
difficult humans are horrible at
imagining the future we imagine better
versions of today we have cars with
flying cars so if you look at uh books
of the future from 50 60 years ago they
envisioned us teleporting and spaceships
we didn't do that they didn't envision
you know iphones and things like that so
uh it's very difficult to say do you
think that the innovation on top of
bitcoin will come from the bitcoin
community or do you think it'll be an
outsiders who are looking for some
technology and realize they can use
bitcoin but they aren't necessarily
quote bitcoiners in term uh as they
create the innovation uh probably
eventually non-bitcoiners right so i
think what happens is i look at it like
a tcp protocol and there's trillions of
applications built on one protocol and
now we have a bitcoin protocol and i
believe there will be trillions of
applications built on top of the bitcoin
protocol eventually you know like this
taro for example seems like a pretty
cool option where we could maybe launch
other tokens on top of that a lot of
bitcoiners aren't super happy about that
but i think about like um one of the big
revolutions is keeping property in a way
that can't be stolen for me and if i
want to send it to you nobody can censor
that right so think about before the
internet how did you have stocks you had
stock certificates there were pieces of
paper that would keep in my safe and if
i had the stock certificate a bare
instrument or a bond right i would have
that bare instrument and almost if you
could put assets back into bare
instruments where i could hold them and
we could exchange them freely so i think
that's probably a big innovation that
could happen and i think we'll start to
see a lot of stuff come on that aren't
bitcoiners uh eventually you know
they'll just be building companies i i
was investing in the early days of the
dot com in the late 90s
and i remember at the time i was young
just starting my investing career my
roommate quit his job and were trading
these things called internet stocks
everyone thought we were crazy they
never heard of these things but today
there's no such thing as internet stocks
they're just companies yeah